no just the sparkling water and a turkey
sandwich and chips and black and yes I
want to see the rest of those baby
pictures Elaine thank you oh my God I
love bullying okay what do you got for
me so finding the identity of these guys
has been like one dead end after another
we know that Hulk King is the admin on
intelligencia but the site security is
annoyingly airtight I've been looking
into the platform and it is owned by
several shell companies that are
operating outside of U.S jurisdiction
which it's like how am I supposed to sue
these guys if I don't know who they are
okay look intelligency is made up of
exclusively dumb dudes one of these guys
is gonna slip up and they're gonna give
us enough information so that we can
track them down and then we will find
them and we will destroy them
legally
I said by Annie and all me no I am going
to sue them for defamation and invasion
of privacy and get them charged with
unauthorized access to a protected
computer boring all right you want to be
on Jen Walters about it yeah that's cool